Google Cloud updates new dataplex
features Auto data quality or Auto DQ
which offers automated rule
recommendation built-in reporting and
serverless execution to construct high
quality data and data profiling which
delivers richer insight into the data by
identifying its common statistical
characteristics both of those are in
public preview and you can learn more on
the blog and other launches include
Cloud workstation support for customer
managed encryption keys and Google Cloud
deploy support of cloud run targets
learn more about all those stories at
the links below and thanks for watching